what is happening reject nation
Greg John hey patron video requests time
whatever video you request we must
definitely do by the way we do
full-length TV show reactions weekly q
and A's and music video covers on our
patrons this is from a man named Alex
gross who is far from that he sounds
sexy and appealing and I'll say about
him
this guy has a big passion for cinema
he's only 25 climbing his way up the
ladder like a good networking guy in LA
in New York should I believe he actually
wrote this video we're about to watch
Back to the Future the ethics of time
travel this is from a channel that they
have called space taste I don't know
what this video is and he said this is
the one to check out and I says okay
okay Alex gross let's do it since I love
you the most
back to the future edition yeah have you
ever asked yourself if given the
opportunity to time travel would you
alter your own timeline would you
manipulate the future of human time for
the better now stick up at one of
cinema's most sellers films to find out
if you should I don't think you should
know terrible integer Marty McFly
scientist dr. Emmett Brown two witnesses
latest experiment doc unveils a
time-traveling DeLorean and preps it at
a time in five 1955 the day he first
conceived the idea
but pissed-off terrorists interrupted
shoot Doc Brown dead alright man just to
escape 1955 and he disrupts the flow of
history after getting enacted by the car
that his father was supposed to identify
better result a younger version of his
mother gets all hot for him there's also
a jerk named Biff who bullies George
Marty ends up finding Doc's younger self
and attempts to normalize the tangled
timeline by having his parents kid you
haven't seen Back to the Future this is
none little perfect weekend oh yeah last
time George comes to the rescue
Marty returns to the Clocktower as the
lightning strike sending him back to
1985 to find that his father is a
successful author and Lorraine is living
large all as well and the future is
saved until Doc Brown appears with a
warning and warps them back to the
future for part two so curious so all
this time travel is possible well it was
all thanks to a flux capacitor
what's a flux capacitor truth is we
don't really know because it's imaginary
at least for now but time travel is
theoretically possible thanks to quantum
mechanics without signs equation for all
plug in faster than light velocity you
get backwards time travel this is due to
a hypothetical particle called tachyons
which move faster than light
theoretically if a flux capacitor was
developed and was able to generate
tachyons in order to travel backwards in
time you'd likely be faced with
something called the butterfly effect
yes that one wrong butterfly you'll
change the universe however it won't be
the universe that you were born into but
rather a new universe that you've
created this is where paradox is coming
according to Einstein time is a river it
can speed up slow down whirlpool even
fork in different directions Marty McFly
travels in the glorious time may arise
before up in a parallel
universe with a new timeline is grid if
you could time travel does that mean you
should alter your timeline now if it
isn't the same timeline you were born
into maybe let's take a look at some
examples when the DeLorean is first
revealed doc and Marty meets in the
parking lot of the Twin Pines mall
moments over there when Marty travels
backwards in time he crashes into a
farmhouse and it's chased by gun
wielding farmer Marty speeds away but a
doing cell runs over the farmers pine
tree fast forward towards the end of the
film when Marty travels back to the Twin
Pines mall we now see that something's
changed ha coupons mom Oh dad I never
noticed that that tree that Marty had
run over and triggered the butterflies
weren't the whole video right there a
lot worse take George and Lorraine's
kiss if Marty had prevented his parents
from having their first smooch he likely
would have never been born at least not
in the parallel universe he traveled to
every action has a reaction
and when numerous people comes reactions
in the end
Marty changed his parents lives for the
better and that bully theft was made
into a loser
but while we cheer and our heroes win we
don't know who else was affected by the
outcome
what did Biff and his father were
wealthy and his mother was poor left
with nothing after their divorce maybe
she had cancer and the only reason she
was beating the cancer was because NIF
was paying for her chemotherapy with
maintaining his mother could have been
too it all comes down to the fact that a
trillion different actions took place
just for George and Lorraine to have
their first kiss any action no matter
how small can have adverse effects on
people all over the world so what do you
think it's time travel ethical we say
yes but only if you lay down some ground
rules before hopping in that the Lord
yeah you guys confer yes yeah leave your
thoughts in the comments below maybe
subscribe and we'll see you next time
future travelers
see that's uh that's a tricky that's a
tricky argument right there and I am
surprised they came out with a yes cuz I
feel like there's so many hazards well
let's talk about a couple things one
thing I want to talk about is something
that's not mentioned the other thing I
want to talk about is where I would time
travel to John who may I proceed yes I
think I appreciate the offer numero uno
my problem with any scenario scenario or
scenario if your [ __ ] [ __ ] what
Marty specifically was having to deal
with and the flash season three someone
kind of did this recently to I don't
know if you guys know this but in order
to be come a baby you're first a sperm
from your daddy yes and that's for
inside your mom yes
the sperm changes quite often yes just
cuz he got them to kiss and just cuz
they fondled one another doesn't exactly
mean that's the same sperm kid that
would give birth to Marty McFly down I
know we're dealing with movies and time
travel is impossible yet however it's
something to consider if you've got the
time in the past which is leading me to
my next point I would time travel to the
future because you can't really damage
anything in the future I guess no if
anything I could time travel to the
future and then when I'm back in the
present weight natural time to meet
myself in that future if I [ __ ] up the
future and kill that version of me which
would in turn kill me from ever coming
back
erasing myself series of misadventures
I'm saying I think it's less dangerous
to time travel to the future yes but is
it when you time travel to the future
here's my other question there are two
types of time travel I've seen in movies
one is like time travel from the time
machine key time travels forward and
that means he's been gone for all those
years and he's in the future where he
didn't exist in never time trial
backhand was just there and then there's
the Back to the Future to time-travel
where a time travels through the future
and he meets old Marty McFly he got back
and then you know lived his life right
horrors is talking about like the
parallel alternate timelines and all
that you know well cuz Back to the
Future I think operates under the
conceit that there's just one timeline
you know you gotta fix it and and that's
like very neat and self-contained but
but yeah the second you start opening up
multiple streams of time if the day ever
comes that time travel becomes a real
thing I think just the universe is gonna
be [ __ ] up automatically because like
we all get access to it yeah well yeah
there is that too is like all you even
if five different have access to it
everything you church travel is maybe
less hazardous because I don't know cuz
now I'm thinking about like well what is
it gonna do to their time because in
their time you don't belong in your time
you're just leaving and popping up into
the future how do I care about their
time yeah well yeah because it's a head
of art yeah not time traveling to
tomorrow until I got older I get I kind
of fall on the ethics side of no because
I think it's a terrible idea I just yeah
I just think to myself I don't know to
what degree the butterfly effect will
take place but I have to imagine it will
take place to some degree my mind I just
imagine like yeah even a small change
could alter everything like mall change
if I went back in time and stood in line
at a Starbucks I have altered time
different people saw you know people saw
me this person ordered later which
causes a whole ripple effect they hit
the road everything changes yeah yeah
yeah and like that episode The Simpsons
has always been like a great example to
me when Homer fixes the toaster and
keeps going back in time and every
little thing he does like drastically
alters the future and that's not far
from what might happen that's the thing
is I don't think Back to the Future
whatever be possible cuz you can't just
go back and fix no you can cuz that's a
great point about sperms which is
exactly why Kyle Reese is not the
original father of John Connor in
Terminator II raised no sense
all even though Terminator 2 is arguably
my favorite sci-fi movie and right next
to the matrix I still have very big
issues with the whole calories thing
being that that's another video for
another time time travels a tricky thing
I think the only way time travel works
cleanly is in the black market they're
all using it to go kill each other and
yeah this was fun this is a fun video
man I thought you guys did a great job
and it was interesting theories
presented
I liked the discussion we had afterwards
well the lone Pines thing I mean thank
you for anyway reject nation thanks for
watching you guys are the light Alex
love you buddy thanks for sending this
our way I mean a patron eject
thank you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation and K click that
notification now and I want you go ahead
check us out on patreon I got plenty of
goodies over there I would love to have
you become a pic throw a jig